teenage Kara zor-el survived Krypton's
destruction in suspended animation on a
craft following her cousin kal-el after
a longer than intended journey to earth
Kara woke to a series of shocking
discoveries
she had incredible yet dangerous new
powers her baby cousin was a grown man
and the two were Krypton's only
survivors while Kara still grieves for
Krypton she fights to protect family
friends and her new home as Supergirl an
agile bruiser
Supergirl charges into fights and
clobbers vulnerable enemies her passive
is solar furnace with every basic attack
Supergirl gains a stack of solar furnace
up to a maximum of four stacks at four
stacks of solar furnace Supergirl gains
bonus true damage with her basic attacks
and the skill world breaker worlds
breaker gives her next basic attack
additional attack damage and will strike
enemies in a cone behind her target
Supergirl dashes in a target direction
with bounding strength dealing attack
damage and moving through drones
bounding strike will end at the first
jungle creature or enemy champion hit
knocking the target down activate
determination for a brief boost to
attack armor and move speed while active
her next four basic attacks will reduce
the current cooldown of world breaker
and bounding strike her ultimate is
Comet
Supergirl grabs her target and dashes
forward
dealing attack damage and knocking her
target down while dashing with her
grabbed target enemies caught in her
path are knocked up Supergirl will shine
brighter the longer she stays in a fight
for a strong initiate open with bounding
strike to knock your enemy down and then
follow with world breaker
next use determination so you can stick
to the enemy with basic attacks and
reduce world breakers cool down while
bounding strike followed by
determination is great for chasing
enemies it's also good for escaping
risky situations and remember using
determination before bounding strike
sacrifices the free cooldown reduction
granted by determination comet can be
used to knock targets through walls
removing them from a fight and isolating
a vulnerable enemy and when flanking a
vulnerable enemy you can use comet to
carry them into your team for an easy
kill Supergirl excels when forging
artifacts with high damage and partial
defense Joe chills revolver velocity-9
implants and Deathstroke's Claymore are
all strong offensive choices it's
building a more durable Supergirl spear
of destiny and sword of Beowulf help
defend against power damage and for
defense against attack damage try claws
Horus or soot of Sorrows supergirls and
vulnerability provides extra attack
damage while her shield is active used
at the right time this will reduce
damage from enemy champions skills and
can swing a teamfight in your favor make
the world a better place one punch at a
time as Supergirl the last daughter of
Krypton
you